walking to osaka district court in
solidarity these three couples are
fighting for gay marriage to be
legalized in japan but any hope they had
ended when the court ruled that the ban
on same-sex marriages doesn't violate
its constitution it's also rejected
claims for compensation for what the
couples say is discrimination
it's a terrible ruling we are being
discriminated against for a sexual
orientation we cannot change i'm furious
and extremely disappointed
this ruling is much like the
government's stance on gay rights i
honestly think the judiciary system is
in favor of the government
the case is only the second of its kind
in a country where homosexuality is
still stigmatized last year another
court ruled that the failure to
recognize same-sex marriages was
unconstitutional lgbtq activists say
it's one step forward one step back
i think nowadays japanese people have
more interest in the lgbtq community but
compared to overseas the country is not
comfortable with them living here i
personally hope that will change
society is becoming more diverse i'm
thinking what's wrong with japan
under japanese law marriage is defined
as between two sexes making japan the
only member of the group of seven
advanced economies that bans gay
marriage meaning homosexual couples miss
out on inheritance and parental rights
the osaka district court says there's
not enough public debate on same-sex
marriage however the verdict states it
may be possible to create a new system
in the future
that though wasn't enough for the
couples who went to court they now plan
on appealing the ruling
al jazeera